hey this is eric nam and welcome to my
wired autocomplete interview
[Music]
asmr
how does eric nam make music how do i
explain that i tend to jump into a
studio or a session with a producer we
just talk about our feelings we get
really emotional
and we always latch on to a word like
lost on me which happens to be
the name of my new single from my new
album but it's like phrases that we use
in everyday vocabulary and we're like
what is not lost on you and then we
started talking about relationships and
love and like breakups and how we just
kind of weave that into the makeup of a
song and then we spend this is like the
weird part out of context that gets
really weird where we just spend time
just like humming weird melodies and
then we play it back and then you're
like oh gosh but then there's always a
moment where it's like hey that's not
bad and in this case it was like
everything imagined now is bittersweet
bittersweet and that's how the songs are
made how many fans does eric nam have
how the hell am i supposed to know i
don't know
for me
just the right amount
how many siblings does eric nam have i
have two brothers eddie and brian we're
just like any other brother though we we
do have arguments we do have our tiffs
but i think that's
any relationship so it's great
how to text eric nam well i'm not gonna
give out my real number
should i
okay this is my number it's two one
three
two six seven
seven three nine one you don't need you
don't need my number who calls or texts
anymore it's all dms that doesn't mean
slide into my dms
how to be like eric nam oh you mean like
how to be like just
outrageously good looking talented super
witty and
hard working
ethical morally
just
incomparable person singer songwriter
entrepreneur guy
dude i wish i knew bye
what did eric nam major in good question
i majored in
international studies with the focus on
political science and i minored in east
asian studies not that you asked what
languages does eric nam speak i speak
korean
i speak some spanish
and i speak a little bit of english
and a tiny
tiny bit of mandarin so those are my
four languages here we go english
hey
korean
anya spanish hola mandarin nihao
clearly
i'm fluent in four languages what
happened to
eric naman's song
nothing happened she and i were on a tv
show for
like nine ten months together
and the premise of the show is that we
were married on the show but we remain
very good friends and um
yeah
what is eric nam's zodiac sign i am a
dragon i'm your the jargon 88 which i
think is pretty badass my horoscope sign
is what do you think
i am a scorpio
means nothing to me so somebody please
educate me what does eric nam
do for fun i
just
drink
is that am i allowed to say that i can
say that right i have a good time guys i
like a good cocktail i like a good
whiskey i like a good tequila and i love
to eat i eat a lot of food there's this
thing called
yes i'll say it again
and it is a perilla seed dough soup
it sounds crazy but it's delicious it's
like a dumpling soup that makes you feel
so good
you're welcome
next up is when children
welcome to the classroom when did eric
nam begin making music honestly i
started making music in high school and
it was like horrible it was
horrendous we've purged them from the
internet
we've purged everything from the
and then i just stopped and then when i
got to korea i started writing probably
in 2013.
when did eric nam moved to korea i moved
to korea in 2011. pretty straightforward
i i moved there right after college did
not know i was going to end up living
there and starting a career but that's
what happened when did eric nam become
famous
also in 2011
unless you count 10 000 subscribers on
youtube really famous in 2010.
where does eric nam shop i go to the
outlets a lot if you go to outlet and
you you get there at the right time and
you become friends with the people at
the outlets it's a great way to get
really cool things that you don't find
in the normal stores for a ridiculously
cheap price don't show up at the outlet
though like that's like my secret okay
where did eric don grove i grew up in
the suburbs of atlanta georgia i am a
southern dude i think i miss
the four seasons in the sense that
in la everything is like the same all
the time where georgia you have it's
kind of
it can be extreme heat and really humid
but then you have a nice fall you have a
nice spring
and the winter is cold but not too cold
but just enough so you feel like it's
the holidays and santa is not going to
show up in
like a swimsuit it's a good mix where
did eric nam live in india i lived in
hyderabad india which is on the southern
half of india for about two or three
months i wish i knew more about it i
wish i could impart some wisdom about
india but i think i would do a very poor
job at it where is
eric now i'm going on tour we have 51
cities confirmed just in the first few
months of
2022. probably to our city near you you
can get tickets at ericdom.com
see you there
here we go rapid fight is there a nom
nice i'm a horrible person is eric not
in a group i am not i'm a solo artist is
eric and i'm vegan i like to pretend i
am is eric nam single i am eric nam
this is not a love song lyrics
give me a minute
this is not a love song sad i'm not an
upsell
i got it does eric nam have tattoos i do
not they they're too permanent for me
does eric nahum have a light stick i
don't
i used to we've made a light stick once
for my fans and it was my logo on like
this house kind of thing i don't have
one
supply chain issues we try to make it
pandemic is real guys supply chain
issues does eric nam play instruments i
poorly play the piano
poorly play the cello and i can hold the
guitar does eric nam write his own songs
i do
i actually have like 17
elves that do it for me but i like to
just ghostwrite they're my ghost writers
and i just kind of stick my name on it
and
you know
does eric nam
dance
short answer yes
can i vibe hell yeah can i body roll
hell yeah can i make weird body forms
that people are like is that safe yes i
also have this other one called for my
new album
where
i was just feeling myself we shot the
video in savannah and i was on a boat
and i was like i was doing this thing i
was like oh this this works
because
it's a dance if you don't like it fight
me
eric nam
goblin are you calling me a goblin
oh
yes okay
my physical album
was in an episode of this really really
big smash hit
of a kdrama called tokibi which is
goblin so thank you for that i did not
know it was going to be in it and it was
a great surprise if you want a physical
copy of my new album go to ericdom.com
eric nam hair
what about my hair
eric nam aesthetic
i don't know i think it's just this
chiseled jawline these broad shoulders
thick eyebrows and
beautifully crafted
eyes nose and lips maybe that's the
aesthetic yeah that's the vibe
eric nam teabox show ted box show is my
podcast we've done
probably over 150 episodes the number
one show period except for this one this
one's pretty cool eric nam kimchi recipe
so
at the beginning of the pandemic i was
bored and i decided to make a cooking
video called nom noms where i am making
a delicious
pot
of kimchi
stew and if you want to make it go to my
youtube check it out
it's really good
all jokes aside thank you so much for
having me it's been a pleasure getting
to share a little bit more about myself
and to answer some of your your most
frequent google searches most
importantly please stay healthy stay
safe be happy and
thanks again for having me guys i'll see
you soon
bye
[Music]